기륵한 시대의 패칭을 나름대로 한 것 같습니다.
기륵한 시대 너무 비싸라는 걸 보고
아! 제가 원유 선물에
근데 약간 그 인물을 보면 어울리는 차량 브랜드 같아.
한장님은 살짝 아우디
아우디 느낌!
아우디!
어, 아우디.
여기는 딱 BMW.
그니까 레제라요.
나는 뭐예요?
여기는 이제 르노.
우리 니 선생님이 그동안 쭉 본 걸로
차를 찾아봤습니다!
중고로 사시는 건가요?
현금화를 아직 안 했기 때문에
그냥 구경만 지금
어디까지 올라가야 했다가 차종이 바뀌는
지금 중요한 순간이에요.
지금 코나냐, 카이엔이냐?
중요한 거는
코나랑 카이엔 가격을 몰라.
잠깐만.
내가 골라줄게. 지금 차가 뭐죠?
지금 13년도 투싼입니다.
13년도 투싼.
대충 얼마 정도 되는 거야? 중고잖아, 중고니까.
한 2천만 원 정도 하겠는데 지금 차이가?
1천도 아니에요.
차량 가치 550 정도.
제가 토스로
벌써 그렇게 됐는데 검색해봤어요.
니니가 사고 싶은 차.
내가 사고 싶은 차?
진짜 근데 현실적으로.
현실적으로.
제가 사고 싶은 차는
아, 사실 옛날부터 카이엔 사고 싶긴 했어요.
카이엔
1억 4천 3백만 원.
근데 연비가
리터에 7.5인데?
괜찮아요?
이거 좋은 거예요?
아유, 진짜.
나 볼라 볼래.
볼라 볼래.
7.5면 탱크지, 탱크.
아, 그냥 가면서 기름 절절 절절.
기름 먹는 하마지요.
이거 뽑는 순간
우리 회사에서 제일 비싼 차 타는 사람.
아, 나 이제 여기서 딱 내리면
바로 1티어로 올라가는데.
이거 끌고 강남에 가야겠다.
도산대로 나가야겠다.
알상근이 자꾸 될 것 같은데.
야, 알상근 차 바꾼다, 이거.
나 공식 연비가 7.5짜리 처음 본 거 같아.
아, 그래요?
이게 보통 몰고 다니면 그래도 나오는데
저 차가 도로에서 신나게 달리고 있다.
대부분 주유소 간다고 봅시다.
무조건 저가 빨리 달린다?
아, 주유소 가고 있구나.
이렇게 생각하면 돼요.
그래, 아빠 차 보여줄게.
오, 엑스.
우리 아버지 엑스야.
와, 진짜 크다.
아, 맞아, 맞아, 이거.
그때 저거 타는 게 북의 상징이었잖아요.
근데 약간 그 인물을 보면 어울리는 차량 브랜드가 있잖아요.
팀장님은 살짝 아우디.
아, 아우디 느낌.
아, 있어.
아우디.
어, 아우디.
여기는 딱 BMW.
내가 외제인이라고 했을 때 BMW.
나는 뭐예요?
여기는 이제 르노.
돌타.
내 옛날 차가 농담이 아니라
에스에스.
이게 왜 진짜냐고.
요거, 요거.
요거.
아, 편안.
근데 슈퍼님 타고 다니는 게
다 비싼데.
근데 슈퍼님 타고 다니는 게 다 비싼데.
지금 차도 이거랑 느낌이 비슷하잖아요.
아, 근데 슈퍼님 돈도 많이 벌었는데
우르스 딱 타고 차 문 뚜껑 위로 쫙 올리는 거 올리고
와, 해야 되는 거 아니에요?
근데 밤에 다녀서 아무도 안 봐.
그냥 봐주면 내가 못 타겠는데.
아, 한참감 이런 게 별로 안 중요하다.
나 새벽에 다니니까.
우리 중에 차 제일 좋은 사람이 누구죠?
R상무님.
R상무님 뭐예요?
독일차.
상무님이 차 바꾸고 싶다 했는데
범블비로 바꾸고 싶대요.
범블비?
와, 이거, 이거, 이거.
이거 좀 관종이 타는 거 아니야?
뭐 있어?
야, 잠깐만, 잠깐만, 잠깐만.
자, 오늘 광고 들어온 것이 이제 불수원차다 아니겠습니까?
아, 그쵸.
우리 니니 차를 골라주면서
제가 화끈하게 한번 쏘도록 하겠습니다.
어?
미쳤다.
아니, 잠깐만요. 저 좀 약간 부담스러워가지고.
아, 부담 같지만?
농담이 아니에요.
네.
여러분들 차 사면 그때 말씀하십시오.
니니야 그동안 수고했어.
아, 이렇게 보상을 받는구나.
자, 니니를 위한
시그니처 불수원차!
이거 술인 줄 알고 위스키인 줄 알고 마시지 마시고.
이거 넣는다고 연비가 막 엄청 그렇게 계속 되는 거예요.
아, 솔직히 제 차 관리 되게 안 하긴 했어요.
불수원차 안 넣어봤어요?
한 번도 안 넣어봤죠.
아, 이런 고급진 거는 제 차에 좀 과해요.
그런 차에 넣는 거야.
아, 많이 탄 차.
아, 이런 차에 넣어도 돼요?
그런 차에 넣는 거예요.
연비가 이미 갔잖아.
니 차 연비 똥이잖아.
지금 그 니니 차 연비가 그 정도 수준이면 4에서 5 예상하거든요?
그렇게 오래 타서 엔딩대가 가득해서 지금 안 나오잖아요, 연비.
그러니까.
아니, 그리고 제가 최저가만 찾아다닌다고 그랬잖아요.
근데 최저가로 가도 경유가 요즘 한 2,000원씩 해요.
3차 휘발유 최고가제인가?
3차까지 나왔을걸, 제 기억에?
이거 만약에 3차 같은 건 안 했다.
그럼 지금 진짜 한 2,500원 갔을 수도 있어.
보여드릴게요.
자, 이게 최근 유가입니다.
미쳤다.
서울이죠, 서울.
우리 1,700원에 있다가 지금 얼마입니까?
2,000원 넘었어.
근데 전쟁이 심지어 아직 안 끝났잖아요.
아직 안 끝났어요.
이게 또 올라갈 수도 있겠네.
요즘 연비 안 좋은 차는 옛날보다 훨씬 더 안 좋다.
요즘에 불소원 자세 효율이 좋아지고 있다.
고유가 시대의 핵징을 나름대로 하고 있습니다.
기름값이 너무 비싸라는 걸 보고
아, 제가 원유 선물에
해가지고
생각해보니까 제가 지금 차를 살 때가 아닌 것 같습니다.
여러분, 이거 타봤어요? 이거 내리는 거예요?
옛날에 아버지 차.
다마스.
니모키.
지금 습관인처도 이거, 아니에요?
아니, 들었는데, 그거.
니모키 얘기하시지 않았어요? 습관인체 이거.
그거 같이 있잖아, 이거랑 이거랑.
비밀이야, 이 정도면.
아니, 아니.
팀장님은 불소원 샷 넣어보셨죠?
저, 안 넣어봤어요.
여기 테슬라입니다.
여기 전기차.
자켓은 테슬라야?
넣으면, 넣으면 퍼져요.
엔진이 오래 쓰면 새까맣게 때가 있잖아.
맞아, 맞아.
이거를 넣어서 세정을 하는 거야.
자동으로 해줘요, 엔진 때?
이걸 넣으면 이제.
그 때를 이거를 없애버리면 연비가 훨씬 살아나는 거지.
참고로 저희가, 특히 제가 사차 같은 건 절대 광고를 못 합니다.
근데 불소원 샷은 몇 년, 30년.
30년, 불소원 샷 30년.
그동안 인증을 받았대.
데이터가 엄청 쌓여 있대.
이거는 넣으면 바로 효과가 나타나는 거예요?
바로라기보다는 시간이 좀 걸려요.
이거 넣고 좀 달려야 돼.
찍기는 시간이 걸려요.
제가 알기론 500kg?
근데 저희 이거 광고인데.
세정이 되는지 안 되는지 좀 보여줘야 되는 거 아니에요?
이거 실제로 실험해볼 수 있나?
뭐 말로만 하면 못 믿을 테니까.
근데 사실은 자료가 다 있어요.
자료가 다 있는데 그걸 보여드려도 역시.
회사 측 자료니까 못 믿겠죠?
아, 믿을 수 없습니다.
그래서 오늘 제가 특별히 이 불소원 샷으로.
넣고 500kg를 달리고 온 사람에게 보너스를 드리도록 하겠습니다.
어? 500kg?
무슨 보상을 주셨는데?
무슨 보상이요?
하루 연차를 드리도록 하겠습니다.
어? 저요?
나 아산 갔다 와야지.
좋겠다.
본부장은 빼도록 하겠습니다.
왜요?
윤보원지는 할 일이 많아.
지난번에 윤재가 우리 사이버보보상 할 때.
하이원 리조트 갔다 왔어요.
오.
죽는 줄 알았어요, 진짜.
10시에 출발했는데 도로가 2차선인데.
사고가 나가지고 도로에만 1시간 반 동안 같이 있었어요.
그래서 나는 되게 힘들었겠구나 하고 영상을 봤는데.
신나게 놀 것 같아.
지 여자친구랑 갔다 왔어요.
아.
하이원 리조트.
어어어.
이걸 힘들었다고 말해도 좋겠겠네.
이번에도 여자친구하고 가서.
포상이지, 포상.
법카로 맛있는 거 드세요.
오.
자, 이걸로 불소션듣고 차도 빌려줄게.
오케이.
차도 빌려주고 반차도 주고.
말 잘해, 말 잘해.
반차도 주고.
반차 한 번 갔다 올 수 있지.
자, 제가 며칠 전에 말씀드렸죠.
윤재 PD 놀러 가실 수 있게.
여자친구랑 가기로 했다며요.
맞습니다.
그래서 좋은 차를 렌트해왔습니다.
제 차 아닙니다, 이거.
임차에 온 겁니다.
진짜 돈 내고 임차해왔습니다.
불쏘자 넣기 전에 이 안에 엔진 상태를
저희가 먼저 체크를 해달라고 했거든요
제가 불쏘자 특별히 기술자분도 불러왔어요
아 네 안녕하세요
직원 분이시죠?
안녕하십니까
네 안녕하십니까
저희가 이게 제 렌테온 차인데
이 안에 엔진 상황이 어떤지
이게 좀 체크 가능합니까?
네 가능하고
제가 오늘 엔진 내시경을 준비를 해서
안에 있는 속대를 제가 직접 보여드리겠습니다
이렇게 정압블러그라는 곳을 다 분해를 해놓은 상태고
엔진 내시경을 이용해서
안에 속대를 돌려드리려고 하고 있고
하수구에 들어가는 것 같네요
여기 보시면
이게 이제 엔진 피스톤 상부이고
이렇게 지금 시커멓게 보이는 것들이 다 엔진 떼예요
오돌토돌하게 우리 곰보 핀 것처럼 되어 있는 것들이
다 엔진 떼들이고
이게 이제 인젝터거든요
연료를 분사해 준 인젝터인데
이 인젝터가 뚫리는 게 굉장히 좀 중요하고
불쏘자 넣으면 이게 반짝반짝하게 다 변할 겁니다
저렇게 돼 있는데
저희가 불쏘자 넣고
이 친구가 한 바퀴
어디 간다고요?
해남 땅끝마을
실제 갔다 와서
그다음에 또 동일한 차로
엔진 내시경을 해서
보여드리도록 하겠습니다
넣는 건 이제 주유 그쪽으로 넣으시면 되고
그냥 이렇게 쏟아 부으시면
이렇게 잘 들어갑니다
이렇게 넣는 거예요?
알겠습니다
끝
자, 안전운전하고 오세요
아유, 감사합니다, 선생님
자, 현재 71,013km이고
한도로 412km 걸립니다
끝까지 왔네
900km 타고 왔다는 거죠
아, 이거 다시 한번 좀 볼 수 있을까요?
아, 네
사실 이 순간이 제일 걱정돼도
기대도 되는 순간이고
실제 엔진대가 덜 빠질 수도 있으니까
엔진대가 덜 빠지면
그 뭔가 약간
오오, 와, 이거 말하는 거죠, 이거
이게 이제 인젝터라서
이쪽으로 이제 연료가 뿜어지는 거예요
그래서 이쪽부터 이렇게 전체적으로 다 반짝반짝하게
아, 연료가 뿜어진 데는 이렇게 하얘진 거거든요?
네, 맞습니다
전에 보시면
안에 이제 떼들이 막 공보처럼 막 펴있었고
이게 이제 각 부품이 어떤 건지
식별이 불가능할 정도로 떼가 많이 있었거든요
그럼 저렇게 거기가 깨끗해지면
연비 절감 효과가 혹시 뭐?
얼마 정도 됩니까?
지난번에 인하공전에서 테스트했던 게
7.7% 연비 개선 효과가 있었어요
7%?
네네네
불쌍쌍한 한 해 얼마죠?
저희가 이 제품 경우는
1 플러스 1에 44,000원에 팔고 있어서
한 개에 2만 원 정도
2만 원 넣고 7만 원 이득이 있다?
맞습니다
5만 원 남는 장사다?
네, 맞습니다
아유, 알겠어요
그게 이제 가장 큰 핵심이죠
자, 요즘 고유가고
또 요즘 주식이 오르니까
우리 친구들도 이제 차를 살려놓는 분들이
굉장히 많은 것 같습니다
이거 찍고 있는 우리 PD님도
지금 이미 실룩실룩대고 계시는데
지금 고유가 시세대잖아요
연료를 아끼는 현명한 선택
이제 풀스 원샷 타고 함께 하시면
아마존 연료비도 절감되고
경제적으로도 이용하실 수 있지 않을까
생각을 합니다
풀스 원샷 넣고 경제 운전하세요
우리도 차 보러 갑시다
가자